we're going to begin this hour with an
outspoken figure in the Democratic party
I'm talking about California
representative Katie Porter who became
the first single mom of young kids in
Congress after she was elected back in
2018 and now she's joined the race to
replace Senator Diane Feinstein who is
retiring
Porter has also written a memoir I love
this title I swear colon politics is
messier than my minivan
Natalie Morales took a drive with Porter
and they spoke about her unique unique
being a nice word for it styled
questioning the powerful in Congress
the drug didn't get any better the
cancer patients didn't get any better
you just got better at making money when
congresswoman Katie Porter takes the mic
she has a plan of attack that you're
feeding us lies that we must pay
astronomical prices to get Innovative
treatments is false her ability to
challenge some of the titans of industry
has made her viral and a go-to guest on
late night talk shows are you exhausted
from appearing in every Republican's
nightmares
um no
no I have a very comfortable role for me
okay if you're full of bullets I'm
Coming For You excellent Porter first
ran for office in 2018 flipping an
Orange County District long considered a
republican stronghold she became the
first single mom of young kids working
in Congress Luke was 12 Paul 10 and
Betsy seven when their mother was sworn
in what advice did you get early on from
your fellow members in Congress about
how to do your job
when I asked about the schedule I said
can we figure out what we're doing
because I need to tell my child care
provider they said well we just can't
run Congress around people like you and
I said what do you mean like people like
me well well you have such a special
situation and I said special there's
like 10 million 12 million single
parents out there the only place where
that's special is in congress not in
America we've got some sand from the
beach this is the minivan from the title
of her new Memoir we've got a a weird
book from an ex-boyfriend we have a
project that I never had time to help my
daughter with with personalized plates
that read oversight Porter says she's a
rule follower while cruising her
neighborhood near UC Irvine's law school
where she used to teach when you're in
this minivan do you ever rock out a
little carpool karaoke well for a long
time
um I didn't have a working radio oh okay
and
um maybe the chicks
better run in the book Porter shares
light-hearted parenting Tales but she
also reveals a darker time as a victim
of domestic abuse she writes my
ex-husband got angrier and more violent
as the realization that they were
divorcing became clearer Porter slept
with the chair propped against the
doorknob it was hard to have to go back
to something that I just desperately
wanted to have be in the past you also
understood the importance of your voice
to be that voice in Washington to talk
about domestic abuse you know you when
that kind of thing is happening to you
like I said it's very personal and you
often experience it alone who do you
tell who can you trust and when I spoke
out about it in the campaign I was
shocked and saddened how many people
came up to me and said you know that
happened to me her kids have grown up
campaigning nicknaming her Congress mom
when Porter won her seat last November
her son Paul introduced her to
supporters recalling his reaction when
Mom first told them she was entering
politics
are you worried about them reading the
book and yeah I let the kids read the
book before it was published because I I
knew it would be painful for them one of
the things they said was I'd like some
time to consider my legal rights
um and another one said sounds like your
kid another one said this is why I don't
read Memoirs so they definitely are
probably not going to be leaving any you
know any amazing reviews on the book you
can get out flour and sugar Porter
travels to Washington at least three
times a month so most meals are prepped
ahead of time and there's a whiteboard
in the house
Congress mom is now in a race being
called a dramatic Showdown to fill the
senate seat Dianne Feinstein has held
since 1992. it's been reported Senator
Feinstein who is 89 is suffering from
cognitive decline she has denied that do
you think though there should be an
evaluation of mental Fitness for
candidates running for public office so
I think the solution to this is to make
sure that every candidate every campaign
the voters really have a chance to meet
them to test them to challenge them and
to make their own decisions about
whether or not to support them you said
at the time you think it's time for
change so were you saying that it was
time for change that Dianne Feinstein
was not up to the task of the job well
what I'm saying is it's time for change
but we also need people who are new who
see the problems facing the Next
Generation or younger generations and
that's why I decided to run Porter's
toughest Challenger might be California
congressman Adam Schiff who played a key
role in former president Trump's first
impeachment you've called yourself a
warrior are you more of a warrior than
Congressman Schiff is Congressman Schiff
is a career politician I think I'm
closer to what what it's like to be a
regular American citizen watching TV or
reading the paper and wondering why the
heck does congress not work inflation is
always complex anyone who says and this
is the Republicans all day long
inflation's bad no Sherlock of course
inflation's bad I too go to the grocery
store you are running for the Senate now
but are there perhaps bigger aspirations
someday the White House I think one of
the things you have to do as a single
mom is just solve the next problem that
that's in your face but I've always been
the kind of person who looked for ways
to to make a difference so it sounds
like you're very open to the idea or the
suggestion well I'm not saying no but I
would think I think it's silly to say no
I think government service is important
let me keep in mind I'm 49 and I'm
considered Young by Congressional
standards I'm not young Botox twice like
I'm not young but by Congress terms I am
and so I think it is important for new
voices voices that often haven't been
heard in our government whether those
are people of color or indigenous people
lgbtq people to look for those doors of
opportunity and not be afraid to walk
through them
now we also reached out to some of
Porter's main competition in the
California Senate race so that we can
sit down with them as well Katie Porter
has been called the Whiteboard wizard
she loves a white board and as you saw
her kids are actually fans of having
that whiteboard in their house they say
they can express themselves and also
it's a place where Congress mom often
leaves them a list of chores
guys that seems like a great afternoon
to me that what you spent I I can see
men and women all around looking at this
certainly in California saying you go
Katie Porter there was so much about her
that was so relatable to so many
different things in our lives and her
lives I'm so glad you brought talented
like it is yes she really does she's
pretty real it's a great piece and I
have a feeling her kids do those chores
that she writes on the Whiteboard yeah
they do while not spreading sand in that
minivan that's right Natalie thanks a
lot that was a great piece thank you
thank you appreciate it